can i ask you a ridiculous question
yeah so i've recently watched this
documentary on netflix about
uh flat earthers mm-hmm
that you know the people that believe in
a flat earth
as some energy as somebody who develops
propulsion
systems for for satellites and for a
spacecraft
what's uh to use the most convincing
evidence
that the earth is around
probably some of the
photos taken from the moon
photos on the moon okay so it's not from
the from the satellite space
yeah i think seeing though that
perspective
i maybe i'm just i'm answering too
personally because i really
love those photos they're beautiful yeah
i really like the ones that show the
moon
and the lunar lander and they're taken
a little bit farther back so you see
earth and first you're like wow that's
tiny and we're insignificant and
that's kind of sad but then you see this
really cool thing that we landed on
another
you know planetary body and you're like
oh okay can you actually see her i i
don't i don't know yeah i'll send you
i'll send you that picture because i
love the pictures
or videos of just earth from more from
orbit and so on right yeah those
that's like a perspective shifter that's
the pale blue dot right
it probably appears tiny yeah and just
that
you know juxtaposition of the
insignificance but
you're not gonna build this really cool
thing i just love that
you